الى اخر المستجدات في الملف النووي
الايراني وبعد اشهر من توقف المفاوضات
الراميه لاحياء الاتفاق قال منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن
القوميه الامريكي جون كابي ان الولايات
المتحده لا تتوقع حدوث اي تقدم في الاتفاق
النووي الايراني في المستقبل اضف ان
الاتفاق النووي معها ليس محطه تركيزها
الان لكن التربي في المقابل رحب باي
محادثات يجريها الاوروبيون مع ايران
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه النت
فايز قال ان الايرانيين قضوا على فرصه
العوده السريعه الى الامتتال المتبادل
للاتفاق النووي اضافه برايز ان الاداره
الامريكيه ما زالت تعتقد ان الدبلوماسيه
هي الطريقه الاكثر فاعليه لحرمان ايران من
امتلاكي سلاح النووي
لقد قضوا على هذه الفرصه في سبتمبر عندما
اعتقدنا مره اخرى اننا على وشك التوصل الى
ذلك لكن ما هو حي هو التزام الرئيس
وادارته بان لا تمتلك ايران ابدا سلاح
النوويه
تمثل طريقه الاكثر فعاليه
لتحقيقه هذا الهدف والتاكدين ان ايران غير
قادره بشكل دائم ويمكن التحقق منه على
الحصول على سلاح النوويه وفي الوقت نفسه
لدينا مجموعه واسعه نطاق من الادوات ولم
نقوم بازاله اي خيار من على الطاوله
وفي ظل تدهور العلاقات بين ايران والاتحاد
الاوروبي قال مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل انه اجرى
لقاء مع وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبد الحيان في الاردن مر- قال فيه تغريده
على تويتر انه اتفاق خلال اللقاء مع عبد
الله على ضروره القائمه قنوات التواصل
مفتوحه واستعاده الاتفاق النووي على اساس
المفاوضات فينا في مقابل
حسين الامير عبد الحياني ان طهران ستدعم
احياء الاتفاق النووي طالما تم احترامه
خطوطها الحمراء ومستعد ايضا الخطوه
النهائيه لابرام الاتفاق النووي اضافه عبد
الله انه يتعين على بقيه الاطراف الاتفاق
على بقيه اطراف الاتفاق النووي ان تكون
واقعيه
نحن مع مراعاه خطوطنا الحمراء
والنصوص
المقدمه مستعدون لاتمام المحاض- المحادثات
والوصول للخطوه النهائيه
لابرام الاتفاق شريطه ان تكون الدول
الاخرى تتعامل مع الموضوع بواقعيه وكذلك
تعاون ايران مع الوكاله الذريه هناك تشهد
على الخلفيه الناصعه لاجراءاتنا واننا
لازمنا انه اكدوا على الشرق الاوسط الخالي
من اسلحه الدمار الشامل ويجب ان لا تمنح
للكيان الصهيوني ايضا
معنى الان من طهران مراسل الجزيره عمر
هواش نرحب بك اييه عمر لناقف معك عند اخر
فصول هذا الملف على المستوى الايراني بعد
ما تبعناه من تصريحات لوزير الخارجيه
الايراني في الاردن
جرى هذا الاسبوع يمكن القول ان طهران عولت
عليهما لتحريك المياه الراكده في
المفاوضات النوويه اللقاء الاول كان كما
ذكرت في الخبر بين وزير الخارجيه الايراني
حسين امير عبد الوهاب ومفوض السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف اوريل
على هامش قمه بغداد التعاون والشراكه
واللقاء الذي سبق ذلك كان على المستوى
التقني بين طهران ووفد من الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه الاحد الماضي وصل الطيران
ذلك اللقاء بانه كان بناء بانه همم اجرى
فيه
يمكن القول انها خطوه للامام حول لقاء
عدليان وبوريل يقول وزير الخارجيه
الايراني انه اجرى مع بريد مباحثات حول
كافه جوانب الاتفاق النووي بشكل صريح
وبناء تعول طهران على هكذا هكذا لقاءات
لتقول انها لا تزال حريصه على فتح قنوات
او مواصله فتح قنوات التواصل وان مسار
الدبلوماسيه لا يزال جاريا لكنها في الوقت
نفسه تقول انها تشدد على خطوطها الحمراء
ما هي الخطوط الحمراء التي يقصدها وزير
الخارجيه الايراني اولا رفع كافه اشكال
العقوبات المفروض على طهران قبل التوقيع
على اي اتفاق والثانيا عدم ترحيل اي ملف
الى ما بعد الاتفاق ويقصد هنا العلاقه مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه والحديث عن
مواقع تقول لك الوكاله ان ايران انها عثرت
فيها على مواد نوويه وتقول طهران انها
قدمت ل- الوكاله الادله الكافيه التي تفنن
همم ذلك همم طهران اليوم تبدو بحاجه كبيره
الى الاتفاق انه الاطراف الاخرى لا يريد
احد ان يقول ان اتفاق قد مات يشدد الجميع
على ان هناك امل لحيان اتفاق بالنسبه هناك
تراجع في الوضع الاقتصادي لازال مشهد ان
العمله الوطنيه الايرانيه سجلت غاب الايام
فقط هبوط قياسي وتاريخي امام العملات
الاجنبيه هناك
تضخم يتزايد اله الاسعار السلعه الاساسيه
بالنسبه للمواطن ترتفع قدره المواطن على
الشراء تنخفض بشكل شبه يومي اليوم
الايرانيون يحيون مناسبه احتفلوا بها
تاريخيا وهي ليله الانقلاب الشتوي تقول
العديد من التقارير ان المواطن الايراني
لن يكون قادرا على احياء هذه الليله وفقا
العرف التقليدي والوفقه همم النحو الافضل
بسبب تراجع القدرات الشرائيه هناك اصوات
في همم داخل الايراني في الصحافه
الايرانيه مسؤول ايرانيون سابقون يطالبون
المسؤولين الايرانيين حاليا يطالبون حكومه
الرئيس السيسي ميلاف المفاوضات بحل
المشاكل الاقتصاديه با من يسمونهم بعض
المتشددين عن اتخاذ القرار على طاوله
المفاوضات انه لكن الجميع يجمع على ضروره
رفع كافه اشكال العقوبات عن طهران قبل
التوقيع على اي اتفاق فيهمنا طيران مراسله
الجزيره عمر هواش شكرا جزيلا لك